les petites mains s'affairent autour de
l'oea la fillette a imaginé sa robe de
princesse rouge avec des fleurs et des
tresses colorer son rêve devient réalité
grâce à l'atelier costumes organisée
cette semaine à l'estaminet café de
magny les hameaux pour la conseiller
elle et ses copines une ancienne
habilleuse du moulin rouge joue le rôle
de la bonne fée les princesses à son
princesse a raison tout le temps de se
faire belle parce qu'elles sont et ce
qu'ils les françaises plus belles les
unes que les autres
les petites ont déjà appris à
confectionner un panier en rotin pour
donner du volume à leurs jupes de crépon
maintenant elle lui apportent des
touches girly à l'aide de décorations
faites à la main il faut rendre le
travail d'ici vendredi où ils auront un
petit défilé donc il faut être prêt
parce qu'on n'a encore pas fait les
coiffes et on n'a pas non plus inventé
les eaux qui seront reposés sur leur
t-shirt un ilya voilà encore beaucoup de
travail beaucoup de
savourer votre carrière david
c'est aussi rapide oui mais sans se
déchirer - moins facilement heureusement
d'ailleurs
alors mes chéris vous remettez des
fleurs jaunes vous reprenez
y en a pas tellement au change de
couleur
à la fois directives et affectueuse
juliette costiou mène à la baguette les
futures princesses qui savent déjà ce
calvaire de rouge qui violaient d'ubs le
jeu marron humains vers du rose
et du violet
elle essaye de faire correctement à ces
s'amuse surtout sept buts à la fin ce
vendredi les vingt petites filles
défilent dans leur tenue de rêve
précisons selon juliette costiou que
lorsque l'on porte de si belles
créations interdiction de s'asseoir
boire et manger pas facile la vie de
princesse